[Music]
and point muse submitted by Joe have my
baby you have my baby and take care of
it which friends with them
oh it says especially not just but it
definitely does not change any sense a
three-star general loses a star after
making fun of a woman's weight she
should because she should not be doing
that endeavor they named how many stars
do you lose well make some three stars
okay first explain the star Frost sure
better you cook as a general Michelin
the Michelin Man comes and goes you're
about a three general like I guess like
just a basic background on like military
ranking so general your officer and then
most people you are lucky if you get to
like oh six or seven like Steve's ground
plate retires of Lieutenant Colonel then
they become Colonels mean that's like oh
why no this is officer ranking ranking
yeah and then when you get up to like
general status when it's like one-star
you're pretty much at the level of a
high-level politician so you're already
being escorted in at those limos with a
flag that has either one star two stars
on there and price setting like the
president yeah there's like you're a
diplomat pretty much two limos in front
of you one behind you those black
Tahoe's like yeah that's the level it's
at if you enter any government building
they have to fly a flag that goes up
whether how many stars you are cool its
foot it's crazy so respect so how many
of these people exist but there's lots
what's a lot like hundreds no not
hundreds but like you'll have like so
they call it theaters right like were
like any type of imaginary war where it
happens so you have like the Pacific
Theater whatever and so there's like but
in every branch they have their generals
but generally speaking to be like one
one-star general is in charge of LA to
started to be like a governor three-star
would be like part of cabinet or a
senator or something like that like
Joint Chiefs and [ __ ] yeah so this guy
if it was a former three-star he's
[ __ ] up there like
he's hanging out with presidents all day
probably saw the last two or three
presidencies you've seen people go from
cabinet to assistant to vice
presidential presently he's seen a ton
of crazy [ __ ] yeah yeah so this cat he
lost his star because he was he would
see this woman I guess and me and Bart
and Joe were texts about this during the
break because we can't believe what he
that he lost a star because I can't
believe he said that to that woman thank
you
he sees a chick in the hallway and he
tells her if you lose a few wrong there
they're in a government vehicle the it's
it's getting bumps in the road so
they're probably on the Tahoe I can say
yeah and he told the chick he turns to
the chick and he's like you know if you
lose a few pounds maybe the vehicle
would have less strain of does he know
and also he that's true though he was he
also one point said to her he goes oink
oink are you really eating again Oh God
and I assume he didn't say oink oink I
assume he went three star general Trump
of generals now cuz usually he's like
this highway guy but I just [ __ ]
locker room Rosa quivering yeah way bar
talking about these guys like they're
like up their diplomats going to like
meeting she apparently world leaders and
he just goes one going to you fat [ __ ]
like you but general so you're not even
gonna see generals yeah on a base
because they're so high up they're being
escorted and [ __ ] like that so you're
not gonna see them walking around a base
but if there was a general just even
walking into like a 7-eleven on the base
everyone is gonna stand up like rid of
the [ __ ] stick in there asking oh you
have to memorize every one that has
stars but you can see it on the
like if you see it one-star general walk
by you're like holy [ __ ] this book could
[ __ ] own my ass right now yeah is
this crazy he said he didn't recall but
one quick incident and he said that they
just had a good nature back and forth
and they all around the office and then
he also apparently he used to drop
packages and folders on the ground and
have his subordinates pick it up like
drop some bad [ __ ] up some [ __ ] leg
oh yeah are still high rank yes other
guys old guys you know I'm sure so if
you saw like a private to do that it's
like oh yeah you know [ __ ] based on
regular ass and a Colonel young kid
intern whatever but then if it's like a
other like a general like a captain it's
like this is weird to put into
perspective so like when I went to Korea
I was a Lance Corporal just pretty low
and so my daddy is they were like it
would be like this guy that's a sergeant
his daddy is this guy that's a captain
and so that's already like two daddies
above me right we parked our bus in a
place we're not supposed to be parked I
see this General come out with a [ __ ]
cigar and he smuggles who the [ __ ]
parked this bus here I want someone to
move this [ __ ] I see this captain who
was probably like a mid 30 40 year old
man sprint into the bus and just move
this [ __ ] and I'm like I've never seen
my daddy's daddy just a minute ago he
was parking everybody yeah because he's
my daddy's daddy didn't realize how
small you are at that particular moment
you're just like yeah I'm my [ __ ]
vaporizer I don't know what even care
yeah my female cousins would bring guys
to the house and they would find out
that my grandpa is a lieutenant colonel
and they're always like sir and a my
little friend are they military too yeah
yeah sure cuz it's crazy it's up there
don't calm sir I wouldn't even know
military say sir and miss I only do that
and people going [ __ ] like this yes sir
don't even know what the [ __ ] I'm doing
again
get your like that was a janitor how
[ __ ] sad bear like this but your
grandpa like pledge of allegiance style
I don't even know what to do no exactly
no that's tight that's a lot of pressure
they don't teach us this like military
etiquette or how to address someone like
like you know how to address a doctor or
like a professor I it's like dr.
so-and-so or whatever and there's all
these different titles and I'm like I
don't know you you shoot guns and [ __ ]
my mom you say sir you say miss you
never say ma'am like unless it's like an
older woman but you really what's the
difference between men and men Israel
she has that white curly hair the color
yes and even then it's probably I still
go for Miss anyone cuz I've never
actually tried ma'am on anybody before
hell unless I'm being a [ __ ] dick
name in Spanish like senorita and Senora
don't ever [ __ ] call me as in Yoda
Oh unless you're actually I said Yoda
know what Senora I thought it's just to
feel married if you're married or Senora
no technically I guess but it's the same
it's like being called like a man it's
like [ __ ] you don't not that old so then
when you're 90 and someone calls you a
ma'am that's okay sure that could be 90
though I can't be 89 years old and
you're calling me a man on @midnight
when she's 89 I know who's gonna [ __ ]
text her tits up ma'am like broken
fingers only ma'am issues so yes so so
my grandpa I haven't talked to me in 40
years John you're [ __ ] just texted me
just now oh we're not gonna be friends
with him 90 we probably are but I'm just
I still don't text my friends you know I
mean nothing a point of never speak to
you he doesn't know so my grandpa was a
lieutenant colonel that's considered a
big deal birthday holy [ __ ] this guy's a
three-star [ __ ] general he loses a
star because you only because we sure he
also said hey like you putting some
undue stress on this thing maybe not two
days trips I think you shouldn't be
discriminating disenfranchised groups of
people like that I think that's that's
what's wrong here
and we need to take this seriously and
someone needs to be taking no dude to a
white man he would still be getting
repercussions I'm the guarantees doing
this is military culture like military
frat that guy is probably like making
all of this subordinates do like MOOC
bong food challenges and stuff man yeah
come and stuff their space with Rob yeah
I do too this this girl she eats all
this food
so today boys you're gonna do the same
thing I'm so confused I got a hundred
hamburgers here wait the ones with that
high up like what's your day-to-day
duties you just pick on your
subordinates that's her mainland won't
work with the CIA and like you're
planning like why were strategy yeah big
global [ __ ] scary things yeah stuff we
shouldn't know about yeah drone strikes
on terrorists and drone strikes on
civilian and make use making your
subordinates to MU punks and then
reclassifying civilians as enemy
combatants priests all vaporize they
were all they're all they're all guys
but they're also writing like scenarios
and drills all the time so they'll have
like sample drills if like oh [ __ ] North
Korea just launched a nuke what are we
gonna do it's gonna take it actually
gives them the prep of like but they're
just constant scenarios going back and
forth they're probably doing like like
for example if you're doing a ignore
theory and just lost a missile I've seen
one of these before because of my
grandpa wasn't so well the first thing I
did is they say general North Korea's
just lost a missile then the guy goes
into the bathroom he looks at something
man he goes oh my what my momma and then
he and then he he pisses himself after
that you pissed yourself
it's until until you completely empty
your urinary catheter and then you call
your mama and you say mama I need to you
mom like I said yeah and then you call
the president if you don't your mom's
out there you call her whatever her cell
phone device was when she was alive you
call her to soothe yourself this is one
of the random person picks up like what
the [ __ ] just part of drills man got you
and then you tell the president you
think he goes and does the same thing
that you did they make each other do
stupid [ __ ] like that right you told
president you're sniffling though you
have to be sniffling you do mr. pett
I'm freaking out I'm freaking the [ __ ]
out you imagine a bunch of old six year
old dudes doing that they really aren't
doing that though sadly believe it
inside we're getting a brick dude
missile lives to be like well [ __ ] yeah
well what else am I supposed to do at
that point well she's the American
mainland are you kidding me holy [ __ ] I
thought they'd be like yes it's my time
to shine game time [ __ ] no those
are the people who are in charge of the
war companies oh they make money yeah
that was a Nicolas Cage that's one
negative so that's a Nicholas Cage and a
lord of lords' guns lord of wars
[Music]